i wanted to know your opinion on this
do you think marion ever forgave mank in
real life oh yeah i she's not one to
hold a grudge
from any nothing that i have
that i have come to understand about her
would make me think that she wouldn't
just
drop it i think the scene i
i think she's smarter than that
like they had a relationship that's
that was pretty solidified and and that
they were they felt very equal and very
safe around each other and they made
each other laugh
and they spoke the same language a lot
of
you know in a lot of ways so i don't
i think she understands what he was
doing um
i'm i'm not just saying that because of
the movie i really do believe she was
she was cool enough to be like
understand what that was he was it's a
story it's a script
it's a it's you know
you know her a lot better than i do
having done this project but i feel like
even in that last scene and the way that
they deliver those lines to each other i
feel like you can feel the undercurrent
of
that sentiment so that was how i read it
in this movie
oh that's how i read in the script you
know
nothing not a lot could probably could
get between them
i think it's quite clear that they're
they're um they're on the same page
no pun intended um
another thing i love about that script
was so funny he was so punny
everything was just upon you see
the line after the line i'm just like
how can you keep up
it's really fun to watch um
on screen i mean from as an audience
member not just
on set i'd be you know i'd be standing
up there in the in the pyre
just listening to his banter with um
arliss and uh ferdinand and i was like
this is so i mean
i could watch this all day oh wait i'm
coming up oh he's walking over to me
okay i have to get a character
because it's just there's just so much
happening all the time
and uh and you can keep track of it oh
that's a smart
script smart director